hello everyone and welcome to mad
simplified i'm dr umar malik and today
we are going to talk about a few
protein-rich foods which can be included
in a vegan diet
but first let's talk about veganism
veganism is the practice of abstaining
from the use of animal products
particularly in the diet and an
associated philosophy that rejects the
commodity status of animals in general
an individual who follows such a diet or
the philosophy is known as a vegan
now there are different categories under
which veganism can be divided there are
dietary vegans ethical vegans and
environmental vegans
the dietary vegans are also known as
strict vegetarians as they completely
refrain from consuming meat eggs dairy
products and other animal dried products
a person can be called as an ethical
vegan who not only follows plant-based
diet but extends their vegan philosophy
into other areas of their life and
opposes the use of animals for any other
purposes altogether
now there is one other type of veganism
known as environmental veganism which
simply refers to the avoidance of any
type of animal products and they are
byproducts on the premise that the
industrial farming of animals is
environmentally damaging and
unsustainable
a well-planned vegan diet is regarded as
appropriate for all stages of life
including infancy and pregnancy as said
by the american academy of nutrition and
dietetics
it is considered to be high in dietary
fiber magnesium folic acid vitamin c
vitamin e iron and other phytochemicals
now i'm sure you must have realized that
there is one very important
macronutrient missing here and that is
the proteins
the building block for your bones
muscles cartilage and skin
in fact your hair and nails are also
comprised mostly of proteins as well
now a person can obtain protein from
various sources like meat eggs and
yogurt but this can't be the case in
terms of a vegan diet
most vegan foods have significantly low
amount of protein as a result of which
there can be a serious deficiency of
proteins in our body
a deficiency of protein can lead to
several complications including loss of
muscle mass high risk of infections
fatty liver
inhibited body growth
increased risk of bone fractures skin
hair and nail problems
bigger appetite and increased calorie
intake which can lead to weight gain
so as veganism is gaining popularity
around the globe it is essential to keep
track of your macronutrients so that
your body can function properly and
disease free
here are a few foods that vegans can
include in their diet which are high in
protein
number one
edamame tofu and tempeh
tofu tempeh and edamame all originate
from soy beans and soybean itself is
considered as a whole source of protein
and is not a derivation of animal
product
these three are capable of providing a
body with all the essential amino acids
and these amino acids are the building
blocks of proteins
they are made up of hundreds or
thousands of smaller amino acids which
are attached to one another in long
chains thus forming a protein
adamame basically are immature soy beans
with a sweet and slightly grassy taste
once boiled they can be easily added to
soups and salads or they can be consumed
or their own
100 grams of cooked edamame can provide
11 grams of protein which can be a good
contribution to your daily recommended
intake of protein
a is also rich in folate vitamin k and
fiber which can help to improve
digestion and overall health
tofu is made from dried soy beans which
are soaked in water crushed and then
boiled
it doesn't have much taste on its own
but it can easily absorb the flavor of
ingredients it is prepared with
100 grams of tofu can provide 8 grams of
protein whereas tempeh is a traditional
indonesian food made from fermented soy
beans
it is made by natural culturing and
controlled fermentation process that
binds soybeans into cake form
100 grams of tempeh can provide with a
staggering 19 grams of protein
it also contains probiotics b vitamins
and minerals such as magnesium and
phosphorus which are really important
for our body
number two
oats and oatmeal
along with several other benefits that
oats provide such as lowering the blood
sugar levels providing antioxidants
promoting healthy gut bacteria and even
lowering the chance of colon cancer they
are a potential low cost source of
protein with good nutritional value
100 grams of oats can provide around 13
to 14 grams of protein which can easily
contribute to your daily recommended
intake of protein
not only this oats are very easy to
prepare and require very little effort
they also contain magnesium zinc
phosphorus and folate which are really
important to maintain a healthy chemical
balance in our body
you can use oats in a variety of recipes
ranging from oatmeal to veg burgers
they can also be grounded into floor and
used for baking
number three quinoa quinoa is a seed
that you can find in white
red black or mixed varieties 100 gram of
quinoa will provide almost 4 grams of
protein
and it's a complete source of protein
which means it contains all essential
amino acids making it a great
alternative to carbohydrates such as
rice and couscous
along with routine it is high in
important vitamins and minerals such as
potassium iron folate and many more
to know more about quinoa check out our
video on quinoa and its health benefits
the links are in the description box
down below
number four
peanuts and peanut butter
nuts and their delight products are
great sources of protein
peanuts are a rich source of protein
fats and fiber also
their protein content ranges from 22
percent to 30 percent of their total
calories
being a plant food it is an
exceptionally good source of protein
just 100 grams of peanut butter can
easily provide you with 25 grams of
protein which is a lot and greatly
contributes to your daily recommended
protein intake
you can eat peanut butter on its own but
you have to develop a taste for it or
you can simply spread it on some bread
and pieces of banana and you have a high
protein and fiber sandwich
or the traditional peanut butter and
jelly sandwich can always do the trick
but be aware of the added sugars in the
jelly
today there are several flavored peanut
butters available in the market which
can make your food delicious as well as
nutritious at the same time
but keep this in mind peanuts have two
types of proteins known as arachin and
conoracans and some people can be
deathly allergic to them so be aware
number five protein-rich fruits and
vegetables
although all fruits and vegetables
contain protein
some contain more than others
vegetables with the most amount of
protein include broccoli spinach
asparagus artichokes potatoes and
brussels sprouts
which typically contain four to five
grams of proteins per cooked cup
fresh fruits generally have a lower
protein content than vegetables
those containing the most include guava
cherry moyas mulberries blackberries
nectarines and bananas which have about
2-4 grams of protein
per cup
so friends with this we have reached the
end of this video we hope these protein
rich vegan foods will be of great
benefit to you and you can easily
incorporate them into your diet
we at med simplified are committed to
bringing you the latest and updated
content related to health diet and
wellness
we also have an instagram page where we
post daily tidbits related to diet and
supplementation along with several
surprising facts
check it out i think you will definitely
like it
if you are new to our channel consider
subscribing you can support us via
patreon and on youtube
take care bye bye and i'll see you in
the next video